bonjour nous sommes le vendredi 11
octobre nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'actu
sur TV film Le Journal de la rédaction
voici les titres de cette édition les
militants PS on désigné à travers la
France leur candidat pour les
municipales cartographies à suivre de
ceux qui se présenteront sous
l'étiquette socialiste dans les Yvelines
Paris Saclay ce projet avec email à la
fois des enjeux économiques d'éducation
et de logement prend forme avec la
visite hier jeudi de Jean-Marc Ayrault
Premier ministre pour inaugurer le
centre de recherche et de développement
d'EDF explications en jeu à suivre et
puis le festival de la bande dessinée de
Lucas 20 ans devenu incontournable dans
le monde du 9e art il proposera ce
week-end de rencontrer une cinquantaine
d'auteurs français belges canadien mais
aussi chinois nous en parlerons avec le
maire de la ville et ainsi qu'avec heroc
le scénariste de la série les profs qui
sera présent pour ce festival ce sera
dans une dizaine de minutes sur ce
plateau l'image du jour pour débuter
c'est l'ouverture de la fête d'automne
des marchands et galiéristes du quartier
de la joule et du baillage à Versailles
jeudi soir en présence de Stéphane Bern
un amoureux de la cité royale le coup
d'envoi de ce rendez-vous prisé des
collectionneurs professionnels et
amateurs en quête d'objets rares a été
donné le thème de cette édition
aujourd'hui Versailles vous est compté
la manifestation des dialars existe
depuis plus de 30 ans elle est gratuite
elle se poursuit jusqu'à dimanche soir
on écoute Stéphane Bern au micro de
Véronique Turbide et d'élodymoine
les gens savent que j'aime passionnément
l'histoire que l'histoire c'est quelque
chose qui se transmet ça se transmet
aussi à travers les objets à travers les
les objets d'art c'est là où vous êtes
dans un vous avez un cadre un cadre très
doré mais c'est avec des cadres dorés et
je veux dire c'est peut-être ces
morceaux de bois vous racontent aussi
une histoire mais tous ces antiquaires
qui sont qui sont ici mobilisés et qui
participent à la fête raconte à leur
manière une histoire qui est la nôtre et
je pense qu'un peuple qui ne sait pas
d'où il vient ne peut pas savoir où il
va donc j'encourage toutes les
manifestations qui défendent à la fois
l'histoire et puis et puis l'initiation
au beau
les élections municipales approchent les
formations politiques dévoilent peu à
peu leur tête de liste udi modem UMP
même si certains cas restent encore à
trancher c'est maintenant au PS au
socialiste de donner des noms ce sont
les militants qui les ont choisi lors de
vote jeudi soir des primaires dans
chacune des communes voici les résultats
pour une partie du département
plus de 2000 adhérents aux parties
socialistes ont désigné jeudi soir leur
chef de fil dans les différentes
communes des Yvelines pour les
prochaines municipales des chefs de fil
qui devraient mener des listes sur leur
nom sauf ordre contraire donné au niveau
national pour les villes de plus de 20
000 habitants et sauf également à corps
avec des formations politiques le PS
soutiendra d'autres candidats de gauche
sur le département il y a des
négociations qui sont engagées au niveau
fédéral donc on discute mais depuis
toujours c'est pas on recommence pas à
discuter maintenant ça a été des
discussions permanentes pour se mettre
d'accord sur des objectifs sur des des
programmes exemple de soutien candidats
non socialiste Voisins le bretonneux et
le divers gauche Jean hache ou encore
Saint-Cyr-l'École avec daniel-garçon lui
aussi divers gauche en attendant
d'autres éventuels alliances les mères
sortants ont reçu le soutien des
militants notamment à 50 ans en Yvelines
de François de Ligny à Guyancourt à
Bertrand Houillon à Magny-les-Hameaux à
noter qu'à trappes Guy Malandain n'était
pas candidats pour être chef de fil
socialiste mais il sera bien tête de
liste en mars Michel Besso Élancourt ou
Vivien Gasc à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
auront te l'attache de faire basculer
des communes des tenues par la droite
quant à la ville de Maurepas les
électeurs du PS sont désignés ismaïlahan
pour être leur candidat le conseiller
général du canton a été préférée au
conseiller municipal sortant Hervé
miquelonge j'ai pas eu de d'échange
direct avec un micro mais je pense qu'il
sera en plus en tant que secrétaire
section dans une logique de
rassemblement lui aussi l'ensemble des
candidatures sera officialisée lors
d'une réunion du Parti socialiste prévu
le 5 novembre parmi les cas indécis
Bois-d'Arcy Claude Villet à 80 ans la
logique de reconduite des mères sortants
devraient lui permettre de recevoir
l'investiture malgré son âge qui fait
débat n'a d'ailleurs pas sollicité le
soutien des militants de sa vie hier qui
ont donc désigné un autre homme leur
responsable local pour les représenter
en mars
une autre candidature a été annoncée à
Saint-Cyr-l'École cette fois-ci celle la
détienne et racimus membre d'opposition
dans le groupe réussir au conseil
municipal une candidature motivée par je
cite un constat de la gestion
catastrophique de la majorité actuelle
d'absence d'alternatives crédible au
sein des autres groupes il se présente
sous l'étiquette du centre et de la
droite républicaine municipale toujours
mais du côté du MoDem les chefs de fil
et tête de liste seront présentés dans
les Yvelines samedi matin à Versailles
le président du MoDem Bruno Tabari
évoquera les différentes candidatures et
peut-être également la sienne sur
plaisir ou il siège dans l'opposition le
plateau de Saclay pour l'heure des
universités des centres de recherche et
beaucoup d'espace agricoles mais demain
cela devrait être une silicone valet à
la française un projet initié par
l'ancien président Nicolas Sarkozy
soutenu toujours par l'actuel majorité
le site a d'ailleurs reçu la visite du
Premier ministre Jean-Marc Ayrault
Olivier Maniscalco Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude
mesdames messieurs il est toujours un
moment dans l'élaboration d'un grand
projet où tout bascule
euh du centre de de recherche de de
Paris de Paris Saclay et bien on va être
un vecteur qui va aider ces PME à
croître c'est quand même la recette qui
a fait que Ben la Silicon Valley et la
Silicon Valley nous avec notre génie
français ben on veut faire la même chose
mais avec nos moyens et avec notre
activité selon les prévisions d'ici à
2030 600000 m² de locaux d'enseignement
de bureau et de logement Véro le jour
côté transport une liaison directe et
prévue entre l'aéroport d'Orly et
Versailles un cinquième de la recherche
française devrait se regrouper à terme
sur 7700 hectares de terrain le coût
total du projet est estimé après de 2,5
milliards d'euros
et pour aller un peu plus loin sur ce
dossier Guillaume Pasquier directeur
général délégué de l'établissement
public Paris Saclay était l'invité du
journal cette semaine je vous propose
d'écouter un extrait de son intervention
c'était un jour très important pour
Paris ça clair et le le thème de la
visite du Premier ministre c'est le
message qu'il est venu passer c'est venu
pour rappeler les fondamentaux de ce
projet un grand projet scientifique un
grand projet technologique qui s'inscrit
dans un dans un contexte dans le
contexte d'un grand projet urbain d'un
grand projet d'aménagement mais je crois
que le l'extrait du discours que vous
avez choisi était le bon puisque le
message le plus fort de la journée
c'est un projet qui dure depuis un
certain temps c'est que c'est une
réalité aujourd'hui c'est que ce n'est
plus un rêve c'est une réalité et le
fait qu'il soit venu poser la première
pierre de ce grand chantier d'EDF et
j'en dis un mot EDF ce sera au total
70000 m² avec un centre de recherche et
le centre de formation de des cadres et
des salariés d'EDF au même endroit juste
à côté de ce grand campus intégré même à
ce grand campus de l'université
Paris-Saclay
excellente illustration de la
coopération dont on espère des fruits
nombreux entre la recherche publique et
la R&D privée
alors qu'une manifestation est annoncée
pour samedi après-midi à Poissy devant
les locaux du constructeur automobile
PSA les syndicalistes Sud ont reçu cette
semaine elle a visite d'Olivier
Besancenot porte-parole du NPA ancien
candidat à la présidentielle également
cette syndicaliste Sud poursuivent une
grève de la fin depuis plus de 20 jours
ils entendent protester contre une
discrimination syndicale claire Cambier
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude était sur
place cette semaine
20 jours de grève de la fin 20 jours que
c'est cette ouvriers syndicalistes sud
de PSA Poissy campe devant les bureaux
de leur direction leur combat dénoncer
leurs conditions de travail et le
harcèlement moral qu'il subisse mais
pour le moment leur revendications sont
restées lettres mortes alors leur lutte
continue malgré les alertes des médecins
j'ai un problème cardiaque et je refuse
d'arrêter
je préfère crever ici et ne pas lâcher
il continue marche il fait comme ça PSA
c'est-à-dire l'indifférence totale la
direction jointe par téléphone n'a pas
souhaité s'exprimer un comité de soutien
solidaire rassemblant association parti
syndicat a été créé le 3 octobre les
membres se relaient pour soutenir les
grévistes aujourd'hui c'était au tour
d'Olivier Besançon l'espoir qu'on a on
verra ce qui se passe donc le 10 après
demain aussi autour de l'accord
compétitivité si ça peut être aussi un
moyen de tout refaire ressurgir à la
surface quoi voilà pas simplement les
accords de compétitivité mais aussi ce
qu'il y a derrière et ce qui vous arrive
aussi les autres syndicats ne
soutiennent pas leurs mouvements mais
étaient unis le 3 octobre lors d'une
mobilisation nationale contre l'accord
compétitivité samedi les grévistes
invite leur soutien ils marchent vers la
mairie à 14 heures
faits divers deux élèves du lycée
militaire de Saint-Cyr-l'École agressé
par une dizaine de jeunes l'information
a été révélée ce jeudi l'une des
victimes est légèrement blessée à la
tête l'agression s'est déroulée peu
avant 17h dans la rue près de
l'établissement les élèves étaient tenus
civiles ils ont porté plainte trois
personnes de 18 ans ont été interpellés
voici la réaction ce matin du chef de
corps de l'établissement
je suis étonné parce que on vit sur
Saint-Cyr-l'École depuis des années
c'est quand même
la ville la ville vit autour de son
lycée et de lycée vit dans sa ville et
je n'ai pas connaissance moi
de d'actes de ce genre là
auparavant donc qu'est-ce qui a provoqué
je ne sais pas du tout moi je me suis
assuré que mes élèves avaient eu un
comportement exemplaire il n'avait pas
provoqué n'avait pas fait quoi que ce
soit pour créer ça mais apparemment bon
voilà moi j'en sais pas plus il y a que
l'enquête qui pourra le dire je voudrais
pas qu'on en arrive à mettre deux
communautés qui ont toujours vécu
parfaitement en phase en opposition
qui a été confiée au commissariat de
Fontenay le Fleury la semaine du
handicap sur Montigny-le-Bretonneux 10e
édition elle permet durant quelques
jours en octobre de sensibiliser adulte
et enfant après une série d'animations à
la base de loisirs de 50 ans en Yvelines
avec notamment rallier découverte et des
personnes en situation de handicap vous
envoyer les images ou encore des sports
des rencontres sportives en fauteuil
basket fauteuil également la venue de
Philippe rivière champion d'escalade
malgré des contraintes physiques liées à
sa maladie ce week-end clôture avec la
mobilisation toujours des bénévoles un
triathlon de l'espérance portée par
l'association médias handicapés de 14
heures à 17h au Centre sportif Pierre de
Coubertin Marie-Noëlle tarrow en charge
de l'action sociale sur la ville revient
sur les résultats d'une telle semaine
c'est vrai que le regard a changé et
surtout le fait que le travail que nous
avons essayé de développer c'était un
travail vis-à-vis des enfants et donc
nous sommes partis du principe que si
nous informions ce qui était le handicap
si nous faisions participer les enfants
et bien petit à petit au fur et à mesure
de leur évolution lorsqu'il deviendront
adolescent et lorsqu'ils seront adultes
et bien peut-être qu'ils n'auront plus
disons tout ce qui faisait le frein à la
connaissance du handicap et le fait de
se dire que quelqu'un a dit un jour que
on était tous des handicapés en
puissance effectivement pourquoi pas
mais que c'est pas parce qu'on est
handicapé qu'on ne peut pas faire
mobilisation également contre le cancer
du sein ce mois d'octobre parce que 48%
des femmes ne participent pas au
dépistage et que chaque année la maladie
entraîne plus de 12000 décès est né
Octobre Rose une mobilisation nationale
qui passe notamment par la danse avec
plusieurs cours de Zumba zumbarose
organisé pour lever des fonds Patrick
ce jour-là tout en rose ces femmes font
de la zumba au profit d'une seule et
même cause le cancer du sein une femme
sur 8 est encore touchée en France comme
Eugénie elle s'est engagée dans la lutte
contre le cancer du sein à travers la
zumba ça m'est venue après le gant de ce
que moi j'ai eu un cancer en 2009 j'ai
voulu continuer le combat c'est ma
manière à moi de d'aider les autres
femmes qui sont aujourd'hui atteintes
d'un cancer et de leur montrer que voilà
on peut on peut guérir on peut avoir une
vie normale et la vie continue quoi
l'objectif de cette journée est aussi de
sensibiliser au dépistage parce que
malheureusement les femmes sont pas
assez sensibilisées on pense que ça
arrive à peu près vers 45-50 ans parce
que le dépistage se fait à partir de 50
ans mais les femmes sont touchées de
plus en plus jeunes et c'est vraiment
important de se faire dépister le plus
tôt possible
même discours du côté des médecins le
docteur mayeur est favorable à la
mammographie dès l'âge de 40 ans plus on
se dépistes tôt plus on augmente ouf les
chances de guérison et ça c'est vraiment
important en plus en ayant de moins en
moins de séquelles il y a plus on
dépiste tout plus on diagnostic tôt et
moins il y aura de séquelles des
traitements dans l'avenir le cancer du
sein tue encore plus de 10 000 personnes
par an pour ce médecin les progrès
thérapeutiques sont considérables plus
de deux tiers des femmes en guérisse
aujourd'hui la recherche scientifique
tente de mieux cibler les traitements et
pour ça il faut aussi qu'on ait les
moyens financiers et ça c'est un très
très gros débat dans tous les pays et en
particulier en France cette journée a
permis de récolter au total plus de 3750
euros pour la Ligue contre le cancer du
sein chaque année plus de 40 000
nouveaux cas sont détectés
et la lutte contre le cancer du 100
octobre rose encore à Rambouillet ont
été présentés cette semaine c'est
milliers de fleurs abritées dans le
domaine des floraisons roses et symboles
d'un élan de solidarité envers celles et
ceux qui luttent contre cette maladie
dès la fin de l'hiver de les plantes
étaient mis en serre avant d'être
disposés à travers ce site labellisait
jardin remarquable de France appartenant
aujourd'hui au domaine présidentiel
l'occasion surtout de rappeler que le
cancer du sens se positionne au premier
rang des décès par cancer chez la femme
on passe à la culture 9e art le festival
de la bande dessinée de Buc va se
dérouler demain samedi et dimanche je
reçois sur ce plateau Jean-Marc le
rugulier bonsoir vous êtes le maire de
Buc et Gilles corps connu sous le nom
des rock scénariste des profs bonsoir à
vous merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous avez participé
activement à cette édition d'ailleurs on
va le détailler tout à l'heure vous êtes
impliqué auprès des enfants de la ville
on va découvrir tout d'abord la fiche de
cette 20e édition du festival affiche
signée Michel Blanc Dumont et on va
commencer par là le festival fait
30 ans c'était un pari osé au début d'un
amateur de bandes dessinées c'était
effectivement un Paris osé parce que en
94 lorsque un but quoi nous a écrit pour
essayer d'associer la ville à un
festival de bandes dessinées on a un
petit peu hésité sur le moment et puis
on est parti on est parti et je crois
que c'est vrai que ça fait très curieux
d'arriver cette année au 20e
anniversaire ce qui veut dire que
quelque part c'est un c'est un festival
sérieux nous espérons bien fêter les
trentenaires on verra bien pas moi
sûrement mais d'autres mais je crois que
c'est c'est un moment important pour
tous les acteurs pour les pour les
auteurs effectivement qui ont participé
de beaucoup beaucoup à de très nombreux
festivals de but et puis pour tous ceux
qui se sont inclus qui se sont associés
si vous voulez pour qu'effectivement ce
festival grandisse grandisse grand en
arrivant au 20e aujourd'hui 20e
anniversaire ah oui bientôt les 30 ans
on sera encore là tout de même pour le
célébrer
c'est un festival qui se veut à la fois
lui incontournable pour les
collectionneurs mais aussi ouvert à
toutes les familles il y a des
animations si on peut juste faire une
petite parenthèse il y a des ateliers
dessin des ateliers caricatures aussi
maquillage vous vouliez ce rendez-vous
pour les familles aussi on a voulu
surtout un rendez-vous pour les familles
c'est vrai que jusqu'au 18e je crois
l'entrée était payante
bon c'était c'est comme ça et puis on a
décidé à partir du 18e de rendre cette
entrée complètement gratuite et là on a
vu exploser effectivement le nombre de
de personnes qui sont visitées puisque
l'année dernière nous avons atteint plus
de 4500 visiteurs ce qui est un beau
chiffre alors nous espérons
effectivement cette année encore aller
plus fort alors je vous le disais le
festival commence samedi dimanche mais
en fait il commence dès ce soir
puisqu'il y a aussi des projections de
films il y a une projection de films ce
soir parce que septième art c'est
toujours pensé sur le neuvième heure la
bande dessinée les profs que vous
connaissez bien puisque vous allez bien
concepteur et scénariste et rock qui
était avec nous aujourd'hui cette bande
dessinée a fait l'objet d'un
long-métrage meilleur succès français de
2013 réalisé par pff il sera proposé
vendredi soir 20h30 donc dès ce soir car
je regarde et vous serez là
effectivement pour rencontrer un public
allez-y au courant
et quel regard vous portez sur ce film
alors justement c'est l'occasion de vous
faire difficile j'ai du mal à être
objectif sur ce film parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a eu des très bons contacts
avec l'équipe avec les aussi bien le
l'équipe technique les acteurs etc donc
évidemment sans être directement
appliqué dans le scénario j'avais envie
d'aimer ce film là avant même qu'il
existe et heureusement j'ai pas eu trop
à me forcer j'ai trouvé que c'était très
bien débrouillé ça restait fidèle à
l'univers que vous aviez c'est fidèle
tout en étant un peu en trahissant des
choses parce qu'il faut le faire c'est
une adaptation et je trouve que il y a
même des idées que moi je n'ai jamais eu
et je suis assez jaloux de certaines
idées du film donc c'est très bien c'est
une vraie adaptation c'est vraiment un
le regard du cinéaste sur cette BD alors
cette BD les profs nés dans le Journal
de Mickey avec votre collègue Pika c'est
bien ça et puis également ça séduit les
familles mais alors également les
professeurs parce que vous faites un
petit tour de force c'est que les
professeurs lisent ça aussi au début au
début nous on les séduire aussi dans la
caricature quand même on s'était dit
effectivement que c'était surtout pour
les enfants et bizarrement quand on
commence à faire dédicaces on avait
arrivé des enseignants quoi et après on
a vu arriver des tas de gens qui étaient
même pas particulièrement concernés par
le sujet mais qui aimait bien le ton ou
qui avait entendu parler de la série
donc du coup alors évidemment les profs
qui n'aiment pas notre BD on ne les voit
pas c'est normal on va pas faire la
queue une heure pour une dédicace pour
simplement pour adresser l'auteur mais
dans l'ensemble ça passe très bien parce
qu'on est notre point de vue ça a
toujours été de pas être malveillant
envers la corporation au contraire de
mettre plutôt en avant toutes les
difficultés les galères et en faire des
gens normaux parce que l'éducation n'en
parle quasiment tous les jours les
politiques nous rappellent régulièrement
cette actualité il y a des choses que
vous vous interdisez dont vous ne parlez
pas que ce soit trop lié
est-ce que ce sera l'honneur de la
prochaine BD le prochain tome le 16e qui
doit sortir en novembre scolaire on peut
en parler parce que ça revient moi ce
que j'évite l'actualité le fait
d'actualité qui risque d'être oublié
dans 5 ans par exemple parce que moi mes
albums sont toujours disponibles
j'espère et dans 5 ans on aura oublié un
petit fait d'actualité par contre les
grandes le fait qu'il y a des grèves qui
a des réformes qui est des ministres qui
changent ça c'est récurrent ça c'est des
choses récurrentes donc je peux jouer
avec ça c'est toujours rigolo voilà donc
l'actualité oui mais l'actualité qui
dure sur le temps quoi 16e volet je le
disais qu'il sortira en novembre 2013
qui sortira le mois prochain on en
revient à ce festival de Buc tout de
même le projet que vous avez mené avec
les élèves ma vie en bulle on va revoir
l'une des planches ce sera vendu lors du
festival Monsieur le Maire est venu avec
cette bande dessinée peut-être la
présenter même si on envoie la
couverture et puis quelques quelques
planches aussi comment vous avez
travaillé ce sont des histoires qui ont
été réalisées par des enfants des écoles
de Buc de Bièvre de Fontenay et de
Viroflay voilà comment s'est passé le
travail avec eux ça a duré combien de
temps je un petit coucou à mon collègue
fera de Vigneau qui n'a pas pu venir et
qui a travaillé enfin nous avons
travaillé lui sur des classes avec
certaines élèves moins et d'autres donc
l'idée c'était de faire une bande
dessinée de cette page en groupe ce qui
est très difficile avec des enfants qui
a priori ne savait pas comment on
faisait une bande dessinée d'une façon
entre guillemets professionnelle sur les
différentes étapes de réalisation d'une
BD donc on a fait ça sur 5 séances on a
inventé une histoire ensemble on enfin
ils ont inventé une histoire et après on
a essayé de faire rentrer ça dans des
cases de découper l'histoire de la
dessiner de la mettre en couleur et en
fait ça nous a pris plusieurs mois enfin
cinq séances en tout et c'est
passionnant parce que c'était une
découverte pour eux pour eux et puis
pour moi aussi je l'avais jamais fait
donc c'est très intéressant pour moi
j'avais déjà fait des interventions sur
la BD mais surtout avec des plus grandes
écollégiens et là les enfants en fait
ils ont pensé que en une demi-heure ce
serait ce serait réglé ils auront fait
leur petite BD et ils sont rendus compte
qu'on avait mis pratiquement 6 mois et
entre chaque étape ils ont pu réfléchir
à ce qu'ils avaient fait ce qui ferait
après ils sont rendus compte que c'était
effectivement c'était agréable de
dessiner mais quand on voulait faire
quelque chose qui soit lu par quelqu'un
d'autre il fallait que ce soit bien fait
et que ce soit fait dans un certain
ordre alors puisqu'on est en train de
parler de ces différents ouvrages qui
ont été faits pour le festival il y en a
un autre également et qui reprend la
vingtaine d'affiches qui ont été
réalisées depuis 94 avec des dédicaces
des photos également là vous vouliez
marquer le coup il y a eu deux ouvrages
donc qui sont édités et disponibles pour
pour le festival on voulait marquer
l'histoire de ma ville en bulle ça c'est
une expérience avec les enfants qu'on a
un bon qu'on a voulu et c'est une
expérience présent enrichissante mais on
voulait marquer le coup particulièrement
sur les 20 ans et c'est vrai que l'idée
de faire un album collector qui
regroupait les 20 affiches et puis des
dédicaces de certains auteurs des
dessins des des des dessins
préparatoires alors affiche des
dédicaces de certains auteurs également
fait que ce ce ce ce bouquin
à mon avis va se vendre très rapidement
il faudrait être présent très rapidement
dès l'ouverture de ce de ce festival ce
Festival qui fête ça vingtième édition
vous étiez déjà venu sur ce festival
lors des précédentes éditions quel
regard vous portez sur les 20 ans d'un
festival de BD je trouve ça très bien
que ça prouve que il a sa place déjà
parce que c'est pas évident de faire 20
éditions d'un festival il y a énormément
de festival de BD en France il y en a
beaucoup qui s'arrêtent au bout de deux
ou trois pour plein de raisons mais le
fait d'arriver à 20 ans c'est déjà une
belle performance et je voulais dire
aussi le fait que soit un festival
gratuit c'est très bien parce que c'est
pas c'est rarement le cas finalement moi
qui en fait beaucoup je me rends compte
qu'il y a toujours il y a pratiquement
toujours un prix d'entrée et c'est vrai
que ça laisse à la porte des gens qui
viendraient simplement se promener et
qui vont pas le faire si c'est payant et
vous y serez présent pour une série de
dédicaces en tout une cinquantaine
d'auteurs et les reins même des auteurs
chinois qui sont présents ce sera la
découverte et puis vous pourrez aussi
découvrir sur notre antenne puisque nous
vous rendre visite sur le festival pour
faire un petit bilan ce week-end merci à
tous les deux d'être passé sur ce
plateau évoqué cette édition
anniversaire autre anniversaire c'est
Déclic Théâtre qui fait aussi c'est 20
ans samedi soir la compagnie d'un pro de
Trappes qui a vu les premiers pas de
Jamel Debbouze Sofia Rama de sa mère
Issa Doumbia et tant d'autres et qui
était surtout vecteur d'intégration par
la culture faites ses 20 ans samedi soir
attrape à la Meurice nous avons
rencontré papi et Mélanie Lemoine le
fondateur et la nouvelle directrice
artistique
il y a 20 ans maintenant que cette
compagnie existe donc on s'est dit qu'il
fallait marquer le coup
c'est qui
on l'a vraiment conçu comme un comme un
cadeau tous les talents qui ont traversé
des cliques plus ou moins longtemps pour
différentes raisons pour différentes
choses on essaye voilà de de mutualiser
tous ces talents là pour offrir un
cadeau c'est un spectacle dans lequel on
fait la fiesta
homosexuel c'était quand même une sacrée
un sacré challenge de préparer cette
soirée parce qu'effectivement
des clips 4 ils comprennent à laquelle
il y a beaucoup de choses il y a
beaucoup d'activités il y a beaucoup de
savoir-faire il y a beaucoup de d'envies
aussi et il y avait en plus l'envie de
surprendre donc il fallait réussir à
faire un truc avec tout ce qu'on sait
faire et en plus des trucs nouveaux donc
on sait faire du masque on sait faire de
l'impro on sait faire des pièces de
théâtre on sait faire de l'humour aussi
donc voilà c'est c'est comment ce ce
patchwork artistique d'une densité
incroyable puisse se retrouver dans une
seule soirée effectivement il y a
quelques têtes d'affiches et j'ai
presque envie de dire j'ai presque pas
envie de les de les nommer là parce que
les gens les connaissent ils connaissent
leur parcours et j'aimerais aussi nommer
tous ces enfants tous ces jeunes qui qui
sont des milliers à être passé depuis 20
ans par cette compagnie parce que j'ai
envie que ça soit la fête de déclic
avant tout et de et de tous
hein hein hein hein hein hein hein hein
alors fin de ce journal à retrouver en
replay sur notre site internet
accessible également depuis votre s
smartphone votre ordinateur je vous
retrouve lundi en direct à 18h pour vous
loisirs n'oubliez pas le 7 8 weekend
présenté cette semaine par Anthony Reich